the five women we honor tonight with
nominations for Best Actress in a
leading role have proven to be as
resilient as they are talented we salute
them for their outstanding effort with
these nominations from Dangerous
Liaisons Glenn Close from the accused
Jodie Foster in Working Girl Melanie
Griffith from a cry in the dark Meryl
Streep and from gorillas in the mist
Sigourney Weaver
and the Oscar goes to Jodie Foster
this is such a big deal and my life is
so simple there are very few things
there's love and work and family and
this movie was so special to us because
it was all three of those things and I'd
like to thank all of my families the
tribes that I come from the wonderful
crew on the accused Jonathan Kaplan
Kelly McGillis Tom Taub or
paramount the Academy my schools thank
my schools and my family my all my
brothers and sisters and mothers and
fathers out there and most importantly
my mother Brandi who who taught me that
all of my finger paintings were
Picasso's and and that I didn't have to
be afraid and mostly that cruelty might
be very human and it might be very
cultural but it's not acceptable which
is what this movies about thank you so
much